it might be normal to imagine that a
good society would be one in which a
majority of people held optimistic views
about themselves their fellow citizens
and their prospects for their collective
futures but in fact quite the opposite
appears to be true deep pessimism seems
a key ingredient for the maintenance of
any good Society at the core of
pessimism is the idea that everyone
however outwardly normal is severely
flawed short-term blinkered vengeful
sentimental and prone to reckless anger
fear delusion and passion with mad
monkeys with a few extra neurons from a
brutal acceptance of this dark starting
point there can flow a range of measures
that together will make for
exceptionally wise calm and reasonable
societies let's consider a few in an
ideally pessimistic society rather
boring and extremely steady politicians
are the norm
no one believes the wilder utopian
promises of firebrand leaders the
electorate is simply far too pessimistic
to trust in easy rapid solutions to any
of the nation's substantial problems
dramatic promises at the stump are
immediately discounted with a wry
dismissive shrug because pessimists know
just how flawed any one individual can
be the ideal pessimistic Society invests
heavily in strong slow-moving
independent institutions that prevent
too much power from ever falling into
the hands of a single person furthermore
these institutions are insulated from
the fluctuations of public opinion which
pessimistically are seen as being hugely
prone to hysteria and overreaction in
the ideal pessimistic Society there
won't be much appetite for singling out
any particular group or class of people
for blame our troubles the electorate
sadly admit are caused mainly by big
impersonal historical forces rather than
by a few people who are easy to target
and cathartic ly to hate because they
assume that it's natural to have rather
dangerous appetites and desires the
citizens of a pet
society willingly put quite a lot of
restraints on themselves defining
freedom not as the ability to do
whatever they want at any point but as
the Liberty to act in accordance with
our wisest most reasonable selves which
only appear every now and then they
therefore don't see it as any particular
loss of freedom to be gently nudged away
from blowing their savings overeating
doing now exercise ruining their
relationships or developing addictions
they accept a paternalistic Society as
the natural price for limiting their own
self-destructive tendencies pessimistic
societies don't have much time for
celebrity culture for their dubious
about whether anyone much deserves to be
idolized they know that from close up
we're all a bit of a mess and they're
not shocked by revelations of chaotic
private lives since this is assumed to
be the norm spare energy is directed
more towards forgiveness rather than
adulation followed by denigration in
pessimistic societies the education
system is elaborate broad ambitious and
very well resourced citizens assume that
the raw human mind needs a huge amount
of structured targeted help in order to
cope with life's challenges the
curriculum isn't merely focused on
technical skills though there is a lot
of help around emotional issues - which
is acknowledged are at the root of so
many of our tragedies because they
acknowledge that we're all fragile
easily arced creatures pessimistic
societies place great emphasis on
creating quietly uplifting and beautiful
communal environments cities are marked
by elegance simplicity rationality in
harmony a stridently ugly tower block a
depressingly chaotic airport a squalid
railway station they darkly admit could
be enough to drive someone to despair
the rich have always recognized this for
themselves a pessimistic society merely
differs in regarding this as a universal
truth in optimistic societies there are
constant claims that everyone can be
exceptional and one day or inspiringly
success
the charms and rewards of life are
therefore fundamentally geared towards
those who make it to the top the best
restaurants are superb the private
hospitals are outstanding the most
expensive schools magnificent the
richest residential areas delightful the
taxes for the rich very low but naively
such societies forget that by
statistical inevitability most people
are actually not going to be successful
at all so in the pessimistic Society
mediocrity and relative failure are
assumed to be the norm and the goal of
government is understood to be that of
rendering an average life that is the
life
most people will actually lead as
attractive as possible
public housing state schools public
hospitals and transportation are all
superb because it's assumed with extreme
realism that we're almost all going to
be relying on them by following such
pessimistic dictates the profound
consequence will be a society where
paradoxically there will be rather a lot
to be cheerful about though of course
the weary gloomy and wise citizenry
would never quite dare to put it like
that at the school of life we believe in
developing emotional intelligence to
that end we've also created a whole
range of products to support that growth
find out more at the link on the screen
now